Er weiß, ob DiMaggio Hovind, Jägermeteor,
dann Spiegel über unserem Wunderland
Natalia-Kindern trifft. Jeder Hund beeindruckt
Tomas Rosicky, um Ratschläge zu erhalten, dass seine Reise nach
China Multimedia bestätigt, dass Osmond ein
Modell des Multi-Concerns ist
gaga zustand über rezeption
vielbeschäftigter produzent ist die
politikerin ladygaga haddad sue bringt mich ins interview
ich habe eine erste frage vielleicht kennst du
sie wie geht es umwerfend
geht es gerade hoch wir sind hier
drin es ist düsseldorf ja ich weiß nie wie
diese sachen aussprechen ich muss
mein deutsch üben tut es bietet
perfekt ausgesprochen okay es ist mit diesem
raum laut was ist das ein kleiner punkt
der soll nur sagen nicht ooh du oder wer in
deutschland bist du es ist ein anständiger dolph dieser
erwachsene jasir hund ja das stimmt  und
es ist, was wir je machen, es war gut und
oh oh oh mein Gott, es ist verrückt, es ist wie
Französisch, es ist 320 klingt
ähm, also ja, also sind wir hier in Düsseldorf,
ja, und es wird f geben  50 60
000 Menschen hier heute Abend Ich werde
für die Black Eyed Peas eröffnen und ich weiß nicht,
ob du es weißt, aber wirst du mich vor
Jahren unter Vertrag genommen haben, also ist es wirklich verrückt
, jetzt mit meinem fertigen Album hier zu sein
und ein Top zu haben  Zehn Platten und jetzt eröffnen
wir, ich kenne die Black Eyed Peas hier,
es ist nur ein wahr gewordener Traum, also ist es ein
persönlicher Kontakt mit den Black Eyed
Peas
war eine
wirklich tolle erfahrung gut ich habe eine
waffe von dir genäht gesehen sie heißt love
kills ya xx was ist dein hauptberuf
du bist regisseur als singer-songwriter
und schauspielerin was machst du so viel ich
bin ich habe ursprünglich als schauspielerin angefangen
u  Ich mochte es nicht, weil ich immer
eine Figur spielen und Zeilen lesen musste
und
ich wollte einfach ich selbst sein Ich
wollte mein eigener Ausdruck sein Ich wollte
derjenige sein, der die Geschichte schreibt Ich wollte, dass es
meine Geschichte ist, also nach a  Nach einigen Jahren beim
Fernsehen wechselte ich zu Mus  ic und
Songwriting für andere Leute und habe dann
beschlossen, mein eigenes Album zu machen und
Musik für mich selbst zu machen, bis jetzt denke ich,
ok, aber diese Folge ist das Wow, ist das
mit deiner Musik verbunden mit der
Webisode, die ich vermisst habe, mit der Kamera
zu sein, die erstellen wollte  Wenn
ich zurückblicke, hat er nicht nur die Kontrolle über
die Botschaft, nicht nur den Ton, sondern auch die
Kontrolle über das, was die Leute sehen, und es ist ein
unglaublicher Regisseur, sein Name ist
Guillaume Dube aus Paris, den er
mir beigebracht hat, Regie zu führen und Co-Regisseur zu sein
Wir arbeiten an all meinen Projekten zusammen,
also muss ich meinen eigenen Ausdruck davon erfinden,
wer ich bin, mit und ohne die Musik. Ok,
wer bist du
?
Rache war
vielleicht ein bisschen mit Hass verbunden, ja, also, was ist deine
Geschichte? Was meinst du mit Töten? Nun,
es ist lustig, dass du das sagst, weil ich
nehme an, dass viele meiner Meinungen und
mein ganzes Album auf meiner
Lebenserfahrung basieren  alles, was ich denke und
alles, was ich fühle, also tue ich, denke ich, ich
denke viel über Rache nach und ich habe
viel
Frustration in meiner Musik, aber
Natalia tötet wirklich bedeutet,
wenn du es tötest, wenn du hundert Prozent
deiner Leidenschaft und deiner Energie einsetzt
etwas, das dort definiert, ja, wir
sagen auf Englisch, du weißt, dass du es so
wirklich getötet hast, wenn ich sage, es ist eine
Beschreibung für meine Persönlichkeit, okay, weißt du
, wenn jemand erschossen wurde, würdest du ihn
winzig nennen
Ich weiß nicht, wie wir
jemanden nennen, aber jemand hatte einen Spitznamen. Ja,
Robert, Bobby zu sein, könnte böse sein
Das Album heißt
Perfektionist Figur. Ich liebe es definitiv,
mich durch meine eigene Vision
auszudrücken  ect passen in Haare und Nägel
Ich denke, dass wir Perfektionisten sind, wir
alle suchen nach der besten Version von
uns selbst, und mein Album Perfektionist hat
nichts damit zu tun, perfekt zu sein oder
es perfekt zu haben, es ist zu erkennen, dass es
nicht existiert, du weißt, nicht okay, es ist  Die
Frustration darüber, ja, und das Einzige,
was du tun kannst, ist, deine eigene
Perfektion zu erschaffen. Okay, du entschuldigst mich ein bisschen.
Lady Gaga aus dem roten Großbritannien. Glaubst du
, das ist eine Frage. Ich weiß nicht, Babs. Ich
erzähle mir manchmal einige Gedanken  es kommt
mir etwas vor sag mir was denkst du ich
denke ja welche elemente von mir sind mir
bekannt die perfektion ja und deine
kleidung vielleicht hast du sie
passiert noch nicht nein nicht du bist keine
kopie keine kopie ein anderer sah  die britische
dame herauf und sie ist keine britin jetzt
sieh sie ist keine britin du
bist britin danke ja es ist ein kompliment ja
natürlich mag ich ähm liebe lady gaga's haare
im moment ist es grünlich bläulich perücke
echt schön und ich finde das jeder der
schreibt  ihre Au  n Songs und ist wirklich
hart wie du in dem, was ich tue. Ich kann
mich damit identifizieren, also finde ich es großartig. Ich
denke, ich wäre ziemlich verärgert, wenn ich mit jemandem verglichen würde,
mit dem ich nichts zu tun habe oder den ich
nicht respektiere, aber ich  Ich finde diesen
Vergleich wirklich großartig, okay, also
vielen Dank, dass ich dir
ein Kompliment machen könnte. Ich glaube, ich fühle mich
mit Lady Gaga verglichen, wie sie sich fühlt,
wenn sie mit Madonna verglichen wird. Okay, ja
, das ist in Ordnung
leidenschaft und jeder
liebt sie was gibt es besseres okay
ich wünsche dir eine sehr erfolgreiche karriere und
ein sehr erfolgreiches konzert hier in
deutschland danke danke dir sehr